foreign
[Music]
Drew Barrymore keeping things real it's
gonna be real talk the talk show host
shows off her very relatable and messy
bedroom in this video on Instagram
Tuesday show me your room before and
after you clean it
I'll go first
everything is kind of all over the place
and super messy and that clutter has
fans saying that is really trippy to
watch yeah Drew's showing everyone that
stars well they're just like us so
relatable while the video starts off in
a room that may need some organizing it
transforms into an area completely
and span
ah much better
[Music]
I am trying to find the balance between
hoarder and minimalist seems the
internet can relate drew the comment
section was full of fans applauding the
Celeb for her authenticity and showing a
real look at her space a lot of my life
has been an open book but let that be a
Liberation Drew's not the only one to
give a glimpse into her messy digs so we
can start in my bedroom which is the
living room so yeah I put my bed here in
the living room and this is my kitchen
area don't judge me Julia Fox shared a
peek inside her NYC apartment I know I'm
gonna get roasted and whatever but
hopefully maybe someone can watch this
and be like okay well maybe I'm not
doing so bad I always keep it real from
Drew Barrymore to Julia Fox it looks
like these Stars aren't afraid to show
off they're not so neat homes keep on
keeping on as Bob Dylan said
foreign